what's going on guys this is Rob and
this is Spider-Man Hunting Craven which
is kind of The Unofficial sequel to
Craven's last hunt it's actually taking
place right now in the zebwell
Spider-Man run but this opens up with
Craven kind of musing to himself right
about what it is that he did to
Spider-Man and the fact that Spider-Man
is inevitably going to come for him
because he's kind of Twisted Spider-Man
and turned him into a much darker
version of himself but he's also saying
things like I am craving the hunter we
do not run I will face the sins of my
father I am my father now there's a
reason why he's saying and really
talking this way because there is an
event that kind of led up to this in the
first place what this did is it really
took place in Amazing Spider-Man number
32 and what ended up happening is there
was in Marvel Comics at one point a
villain called the sin eater and what it
did is it basically absorbed The Sims of
Norman Osborne basically like all the
things that made him evil and all the
evil things he did but regardless of
what name you would choose to assign to
it there was a woman by the name of Dr
Kafka also known as Queen Goblin and she
had become that character by virtue of
Norman Osborne sins that were injected
into her the idea was to extract those
sins and put them back into Norman
Osborne who had since become a superhero
known as the gold Goblin after getting
rid of all of his evil and becoming a
good guy what ended up taking place here
is that in the midst of this conflict
Craven who had the sins confined into
his staff had gone to kill Norman
Osborne and Peter had jumped in the way
so he's basically the one that's
carrying around Norman since hence the
reason why he seemed so dark and twisted
which you will see over the course of
this the other part of this is yes this
is Craven but no it's not Craven so the
idea is that he's not the original
Craven the hunter instead he's one of 80
clones that were created by the high
evolutionary at the request or the
behest of Craven the hunter in order to
cure himself of his immortality there's
a whole great big huge history behind
that it's not overly necessary here but
this clone refers to the original Craven
as his father so that's why you get
those references that go on there but
the bigger point is that where Craven is
preparing for his hunt against
Spider-Man which is normal like
Philadelphia guys who are unfamiliar
with Craven it's almost kind of like a
ceremonial thing when he prepares to
like hunt a Target or something along
those lines there's a whole sort of
process that he undergoes to get himself
ready right it's like it's like a girl
getting ready to go out on Friday right
like it's a whole process you know what
I mean like but what ends up happening
is that instead of him undergoing all of
this Peter sneaks up on him and Peter
injects him with a kind of serum and
then Craven ultimately ends up fleeing
but for Peter Parker because he's so
dark and twisted it's almost a game of
sport there's a kind of fun that goes
into this he tells him to run now the
reality here and this is something that
I want to point out it's one of the
things that makes this so incredibly
cool
99.9 of stories involving Spider-Man are
him just swinging through New York and
doing a thing and then coming across a
villain who happens to be doing another
thing and then the two of them fight
Peter wins and the villain gets shuffled
off to like the raft right the prison
for super powered villains or something
along those lines this gives us a side
of Peter what if he becomes the hunter
how good would he be and the reality is
he is amazing as a hunter because
between his proportional strength of a
spider and the fact that he's able to
like kind of sleuth and use Espionage
tactics and so on and so forth he can be
very very sneaky he is this exceedingly
dangerous guy because Craven is one of
the best hunters and best trackers in
the entirety of the Marvel Universe the
only people that I would argue are
probably more capable than he is would
be like Wolverine and x-23 there may be
a couple other people whose names I'm
not thinking about at the moment but
Craven is certainly in the top five but
for every step he takes Spider-Man is
literally stalking him right for every
place he hides Spider-Man is watching
him there comes to a point when he's
like hiding under basically a bridge
trying to dodge Peter Parker right
trying to avoid Spider-Man catches him
and literally just grabs him and like
snaps his arm and like it's crazy to see
that happen because he overcomes him and
he says I can't believe I was ever
scared of you I can't believe I let you
get away with what you did for all those
years and of course we'll talk about
that when we cover the conclusion of
Craven's last hunt and where Craven says
I'm not my father the response to
Spider-Man is close enough because
you're still doing the exact same thing
that your father did and like throws him
down a Waterway and then just kind of
like continues on his own hunt so it's
one of those things where like it's not
really even Craven getting the upper
hand here it's Spider-Man toying with
him the entire time now there are also
some differences to know and people who
are huge fans are craving the hunter
will point this out if they haven't
already pointed it out in the comments
section right you guys are quick to
point out flaws like Nerf actually rough
so here's the thing right when it comes
to car even Craven like the original
Craven he'd been hunting for years years
and years and years and years his skills
were honed like the point of a needle
right I mean this guy was prodigious
this clone of him despite having every
ounce of ability that his father has if
we want to use that term he doesn't
quite have the history there so if this
were to happen with Peter Parker and the
original Craven it may transpire far
differently so the bigger point that I'm
making here is there's some inexperience
that's coming to bear with this whole
conflict but what ends up happening is
Craven himself basically takes to the
sewers below New York because in a lot
of ways the sewers down there are just a
giant Maze and for all the abilities
that Spider-Man has the ability to like
snip out his opponent by using scent and
things like that that's not there right
that doesn't really exist so he would
have to track him the old-fashioned way
Assuming he's not watching him already
which he actually is because as he's
making his way through these sewers
Spider-Man is just kind of like crawling
over top of the sewers keeping an eye on
him it's really spooky but it's really
really cool at the same time but that's
when we end up finding out the nature of
this serum that Craven was injected with
it wasn't going to actually do anything
to him instead it was designed to
attract something else these are called
Vermin now these Vermin played a role to
a degree in the original Craven's last
hunt Story the fact that they're being
featured here is just a great callback
to that original story itself during
that comic there was a point where
Craven was like masquerading as
Spider-Man and he ended up fighting
Vermin who basically escaped the sewers
of New York and then started like
attacking people and so on and so forth
they're not that dissimilar from like
the molloids the forces of the mole men
that reside underground that's one of
the cool things about Marvel if you read
long enough you start to realize very
very fast that the Marvel landscape on
Earth is much much bigger than just like
X-Men Avengers miscellaneous other
super-powered Heroes and teams the
malloy's underground the eternals the
deviants but there's like a lot of stuff
that goes on there it's wildly expansive
and really has been for a number of
years but these Vermin immediately
attack Craven and Spider-Man just kind
of watches on but the reality here is
that Craven is fighting for his life and
he's killing these guys every chance he
gets because if he doesn't they will
kill him and so Peter Parker wanting to
maintain or at least kind of being
pushed by this somewhat evil nature of
himself actually rescues Craven the
hunter from the Vermin for no other
reason than the fact that it allows him
to continue the hunt it allows him to
continue tormenting Craven the hunter
which he does right Craven's more or
less unconscious at this point
Spider-Man grabs him and basically just
drags him off tosses him into a coffin
gives him his gun and then buries him
alive a very fitting end to this version
of Craven which is a fantastic callback
to Craven's last hunt because in that
story Craven overpowers Spider-Man
shoots him with a rifle and then buries
him right so it's just a great reference
and a reversal of roles based on all of
this so with that being said guys we're
going to bring this to an end this is
part of the current Spider-Man run let
me know if you guys want me to continue
covering this if you didn't see our
Craven's last hunt video make sure you
click this link to the playlist and I
will catch you all later
peace